what kid wants to play with a potato now
who cares
i don't care if the potato dude this
that's not a real mr potato mr potato is
a man
he's a grown man he got his feet out
like that he got some mustache
glasses he kind of looks like he
probably did a crime and now he's hiding
you know he looks a little polish but
maybe also kind of urban bro
you know kind of afro-polish maybe if
you look at him basic you know
if he's that kind of idaho kind of gold
you know
but now if they want a potato that got
you know both
you know that's not a real that's not mr
potato they got a new thing
they got that dual crotch rusted they
got that dual crotch rusted fam
and that's chill just say that
like i think some of the articling
is just to create a stir just say look
we got that dcr
baby all right we got you know what i'm
saying
poppy mommy got that mixed bag but what
kid is still
playing with a potato
i can't you can i you can't i i don't
know one kid you can get off his ipad
long enough to even discuss a vegetable
all
kids want to know now in days is is elon
musk
their dad is elon musk my dad
that and if the answer is no then there
but they don't
it's that's it the rest of their lives
they'll spend in therapy wishing he was
that's all that's it is
my dad
they don't care what kind of [ __ ]
crotch the vegetable has
if we want to do a toy where they where
they get to discuss
gender let's do operation that way
let the kid build whoever they want
this bobby sue right here he gots the
teddy in the root
party on bro you know invite them to the
freaking
var mitzvah dog let's do it but let the
kid have a say-so in it i think
do let him let him have operation you
got the mustache
you got that freaking that wild oyster
bruh let's do it
that's what i say just let the kid have
a little bit of say so
in in the thing or just do transformers
if you're gonna make something
completely open an open
toy do transformers
they're i mean they're they're kind of
asking for it
but let the child or the have it say so
anything
or do teddy ruxpins dude teddy ruxin he
got the cord on the back
yeah you know well i want waffles
you know i thought i'm supposed to be a
bear
you know do teddy ruxpins he got the
thing on the back
you know man won't you be my friend
you know my my penis has ovaries
but i'm only five who who wants to see
my menstrual cycle
let the animal or the kid have a say-so
in it
that's what i think
that's but what also what do i know i'm
not a child
if it if you see me shopping for toys
for kids though
that's an even bigger issue so
when you see people shopping for toys
for children
and they don't have a children with them
and it's december or it's
and it's not december
we got way bigger issues than uh
you know gender gender gen
genders gen hymn gendyms genders
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one